I'm black because I'm black and I said
like whale sharks I'm like oh that must
mean a whale and a shark have sex and
then I think well how do how does a
whale and a shark have sex basically the
Dolphins have sex with each other but
the Sharks don't so I thought then how
is it such a thing is this chicken what
I have or is this fish I know it's tuna
but it says chicken
by the sea
so stupid
[Music]
awesome
what
don't make fun of me right now I'm not
in the mood you act like you've never
had tuna before
I've had tuna fish like sandwiches and
stuff like this maybe you and I have
eaten tuna like this before why is it
called chicken by this city or in the
sea chicken of the sea is the brand
and by the way for all you kids watching
at home Santa just is white just because
it makes you feel uncomfortable doesn't
mean it has to change you know I mean
Jesus was a white man too are you
telling me that if you don't have sex
you can still get pregnant yes because
sperm lives inside the vagina for three
days who taught you this uh she went to
school and you should be happy your
daughter has an education especially sex
ed you obviously didn't that's why you
have multiple baby daddies and thousands
of children my boobs are so tight I
can't breathe what are the three states
of matter
the states like in the United States
what does NaCl stand for
geometry here's a Hint it could be found
at the dinner table turkey
steak
[Music]
water do you think we will ever see a
female Dalai Lama if people don't come
the female must be very very attractive
more useful
do you like
teenage girls
when you say Teenage how are we talking
girls who are teenagers 19.
that's why I don't eat freaking Lobster
or anything like that because they're
alive when you kill it when you hear
about slavery for 400 years for 400
years that sounds like a choice
like you was there for 400 years and
it's all of y'all Or how many Earth
places are there in the solar system
Earth places the round uh planets oh God
girl just because I'm a public figure
doesn't mean I ask for this it does not
mean that it comes with the territory
it's my body it should be my choice and
the fact that it's not my choice is
absolutely disgusting it's not your
choice it's in the cloud and I've looked
several times
so I guess I'm disgusting for looking
clap if you've looked at Jennifer
Lawrence's hacking pictures
that's the girl the famous girl there's
a famous girl on a picture there's a few
famous girls on a picture I keep wanting
to say Marie Antoinette she was the
famous woman yeah I don't remember the
girl that was sitting there like this
she was like
Mona Lisa yes that's my girl in a number
of states the laws allow a baby to be
born
from his or her mother's womb in the
ninth month
it is wrong it has to change and by the
way you know I sit on the stand and it
get hot I got a lot of I got hairy legs
that turn that that that that that that
that that turn uh um blonde in the sun
and the kids used to come up and reach
in the pool and rub my leg down so it
was traded and then watch the hair come
back up again and look at it so I
learned about roaches I learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and I love kids jumping on my lap oh my
vagina is out Budapest is the capital of
what European country Nathan has already
locked in I thought Europe was a country
like I want to say is France a country
I've been with goats sheep cows horses
so what is carpe diem mean I think it
means like Zen it means seize the day
how come I don't know that you went to
school a long time ago hydrogen is at
the top of the food chain solar system
periodic table what is a hydrogen
hydrogen peroxide is that what they used
to put down their eyebrows my favorite
dish I like mugs because they're very
comfortable in your hand and they hold
the hot things that you don't have to
touch so um you know coffee or hot tea
that rehab that her father forced her
into was a rehab where they knew the
paparazzi was there every day how dare
you Mr Spears you had me fooled and you
too Mrs Spears death to all of them
it's like I have to poop I'm getting
nervous
because you're excited yeah and every
time I get excited I have to poop at
night I be flying
I Believe I Can Fly
I am a unicorn
you are a unicorn we are unicorns
do you know how powerful you are
do you believe the Earth is round or
flat the Earth is flat oh here we go
I think you need to do research on it
like ultimately I'm not gonna say the
research that you do is gonna give you
the and like oh who actually has the
answer because it's right in front of
our faces I'm telling you it's right in
front of our faces they they lie to us
who
look for for what I've known for as many
years
what I've been taught is that the Earth
is round yes but I mean can you really
think of us rotating around the Sun and
all planets aligned rotating in specific
dates being perpendicular with what's
going on with these planets
they're particularly putting you in the
direction of what to believe and what
not to believe there is no there is no
concrete information except for the
information that they're giving us and
the truth is right there you just gotta
go searching for it
[Music]
are a lot of Latinos here in this
country that do agree that the
immigration problem is a problem and it
does need to be addressed and it does
need to be fixed interesting but making
those comments those racist comments do
not help and if you if you kick every
Latino out of this country then who is
going to be cleaning your toilet Donald
Trump oh that's in the sense that no you
know what I mean like when I'm saying
that there's more there's more jobs
are not only the only people mean it
like that come on no I would never mean
it like that okay I'm not part of this
argument what planet can sometimes be
seen with the naked eye
Mars I'm gonna say Mars because it's
like a red it's a red dot it Clips
Eclipse you can see the Planet Eclipse
this Final Answer here's a Hint it is
the brightest planet oh son wait what
the star girl I love that color that's
such a happy beautiful Rich it almost
kind of looks like what the earth looks
like when you're a bazillion miles away
from the planet yes yes I just flinted
at it from the planet Moon from the
planet isn't the moon a star the no the
Moon is the planet the sun is a star is
the moon really a planet the Moon is a
planet don't look at me like that the
sun is a star is the sun not a star I
don't know what the sun is the sun is
the sun is a star
[Applause]
didn't you do that thing in grade school
where you had to name the planets and
there was Uranus and there was Saturn
and the one with the Rings and that and
then the Earth and with the Moon is
never in there dude it's not a planet
all right here look this is Key Lime I
don't know I don't know what it is
blonde of mine
could be real okay um the Moon is what
a natural natural live on it that means
it's a planet is that what Google said I
don't know no I don't like that at all I
don't even know what that means